and for game of the year first of all I
want to start with one that's pretty
divisive I feel I feel that people who
are into this game or really into it and
then there's a sort of a large sea of
apathy for the folks who have to engage
with it and it's that type of game
destiny Chris destiny yeah I'm on the
thumbs up - Tiffany I really dig it I
played the first sort of campaign stuff
levelling up stuff during our live
stream right and so that was a lot of
camaraderie were three of us sitting on
the couch for hours just playing and I
was that was a good time but what has
really cemented destiny for me as one of
my favorite experiences this year is
like raiding and week after week visit
like going back with my same crew of
GameSpot folks here going back trying
that again and again trying to do better
and better doing strikes together and
like you know I I haven't really never
gotten into an MMO deep into real life
you know and I'm not gonna say that you
know this is there's there comparisons
to be made but it's far from an MMO
still the fact that I'm coming in every
week and erekt a is talking to me about
like yeah that's telling about gun and
like how it has these different
properties and where you can get it I'm
listening with fascinated interest I'm
surprising myself but I think that's
just a testament to the kind of world
that destiny has created that allows
people that makes room for people to get
so into it there is a big group of folks
in the room next door including Eric Tay
who did not sleep last night
because he was playing at the dark below
I guys who are really into destiny I
sort of wasn't too hot honest Kevin you
were kind of in the same again this this
is one of those points where we where I
think it's worth pointing out that we're
not a hive mind yes yeah and because you
know I think
crazy I'm getting no it's it's I you
know it's interesting how everywhere
feelings on destiny are you know so
maybe you know I certainly give it
credit for being able to pull out really
strong feelings yeah that's gonna be
people see when when our winner is
revealed if it's if it's number one on
off a couple of repeat visitors this
time first of all Dragon Age Inquisition
Alexa fantastic game on a bunch of
platforms staying on the ps4 yep I
something else we didn't get to mention
last time to like the romance aspects
you know we were watching that video
it's just so beautifully written it's
such a good job of portraying like real
human relationship or real fantasy weird
alien way relationships should we made
all right the words can already
mentioned the exact thing we're talking
about Iron Bowl tires so there's you can
you can romance iron bull who's this
song is honking big hulking are Inari
guards and he's just jacked Aztec yeah
so basically like there's this great
Canaria you can do like qunari on qunari
romance for example and finally oh yeah
and like this guy gets a little into S&M
a because it turns out like it's it's
just adorable and funny and emotional
and honestly a little uncomfortable
watching it's not pretty high yeah
alright there you go video games 2014
and get Magic with me they boning each
other you can also if you want have your
friend in a sort of one person
gyrocopter type thing and then hook
yourself on to it and fly around and
chew elephants far cry 4 all I think I
still talk about boning I mean there's
no boning is there's no avoiding a
forever there isn't there's a hell of a
lot of that Ubisoft game play lots of
taking over bases lots of radio towers
it's fair to say it's very similar to
Far Cry 3 as it turns out I don't really
care
we didn't wreak air it's a great game
you get the wingsuit early on and this
whole area is just your playground I
mean yeah especially cruising around the
gyrocopter the mobility stuff allows you
to have to like just lean way more into
that open-world freedom and may
the Far Cry series does so well and it's
gorgeous also that's the story is pretty
great I actually you know gave a crap
about these people fighting for the
golden path and AJ history super
interesting object baikinman odd
jiggling and pagan min is this a super
charismatic awesome you just love to
hate him yeah it's a shame he wasn't in
it a little bit more of it than I guess
you can't have everything a great
open-world game but not the only great
open-world game we have on our list of
best PlayStation 4 games of the year and
this is the first time we're going to
see the mention of middle-earth shadow
of Mordor yeah it's I mean Nemesis
system like there's no other game out
there in which you can very personally
craft like your own ultimate enemy like
there's so much going on there and all
of these orcs that you encounter have
you know a different name different set
of abilities different set of weaknesses
so you have to go into attacking them
differently and the way that they're set
up the hierarchy of their their military
you can either infiltrate it stealthily
from the bottom or just go take out
everyone from the top or you can brand
them which means you take control of
them and then send them in to do your
bidding for you it's crazy you're
essentially a I don't want to call it's
like like one person are mean one person
are in in Mordor and also it just looks
great it's super fun the combat is super
satisfying like you've kind of kind of
weak in the beginning but the game does
a good job of making you want to get
better and by the end you have these
fire fighting so it's like 20 orcs and
you're flipping around popping heads and
stabbing them and it just makes you feel
powerful
I remember Kevin you said it was a
system that you think will be copied the
most in 2015 we always see that every
year there's like one mechanic that you
kind of you kind of think and maybe hope
that a lot of other games will adopt it
as well yeah I would I would say that
the Nemesis system the Nemesis system is
probably the one most likely to be to be
looked at and not necessarily copied but
be an inspiration for other games yeah
for big games there our fifth nominee is
quite a small one from made here
actually right in the Bay Area
correction it is supergiant is it's a
good point
it is super giant super against our own
Greg Gustav and of course transistor
wonderful game one of my top two games
of the year so I'm figuring out after
one year for me personally but a
wonderful game as for anyone who's
played Bastion you kind of have a little
bit of idea of what to expect but then
it totally flips
I tell you when you actually start to
play I mean it's sort of in this in the
kind of the artistic style and not the
like the artistry I guess behind it not
the art style because it's it's
different than Bashan it's a different
world it's the technological world it's
this kind of noir Art Deco hybrid thing
but the the artistry there and also to
me one of the things that really drew me
in was the mystery like this is this is
a strange place and they're giving me
bits but they're also doing that thing
that I love in fiction where they give
you information treating you like you
know know this world and know it already
is yeah but that's enough to like for
you to start to construct the structure
behind it and so that always draws me in
and how about that soundtrack yes I good
point well God pointed out worth
mentioning and the dedicated sing button
oh yeah that's forget the Nemesis system
that's the one mechanic that we're gonna
see in that 2015 or video games so those
are our five nominations for a
PlayStation 4 game of the year right
here on GameSpot calm so make sure you
check back December 15th when we'll be
announcing both the PlayStation 3 and
PlayStation 4 winners right here on
GameSpot